we actually have a caller yeah let's do
it let's take this call from San Diego
okay
Jeff hi welcome to Startalk radio cosmic
queries edition mm-hmm so what do you
got
so my 9 year old daughter and I want to
know now that curiosity's been on Mars
for over a year but that sounds like
this really his 9 year old daughter who
wants to know yeah yeah he's trying to
slide in on her he hurt you yes yeah
okay
they found that Mars had favorable
conditions for microbial life billions
of years ago
yeah after in the Merc microbial life
part billions of years ago do you think
we'll find evidence of actual life first
on Mars on one of the new earth-like
planets that they keep finding oh yeah
great question so if we find life on
Mars it's not gonna be like a
civilization whose beaming radio waves
to us right it will be someone playing
our Elvis record that's backwards
yeah it's meant to be heard yes so on
Mars
it's the microbial life that we're eager
to find and to the biologist I mean I'm
not a biologist but I think I can speak
for them when I say if they find any
kind of life at all whether or not we
deem it intelligent it would be an
amazing discovery the greatest discovery
in the history of biology to my life
that had formed independently of life on
Earth right on Mars or anywhere else if
there was water it's sort of likely
right well any water on earth every
place there's liquid water on earth
there is life even the Dead Sea yeah
where people just didn't have
microscopes to see life smaller than the
resolution limits of their eyeballs and
so they say therefore it's dead you know
you just don't know how to see yet all
right so where is these exoplanets these
planets that might be in the Goldilocks
zone around other stars if we find life
on those we're not looking at
microbially I mean there are tricky ways
we can invoke a clever ways we can test
to see if it has microbes we'd be
looking at would have hold biomarkers we
lose the microbe admits methane for
example yeah methane is not stable on
its own it has to be churned out by some
process and life is something that can
look for methane in its atmosphere rocks
would we be able to find methane on Mars
with very careful measurements we're at
the cusp of being able to look at the
atmospheric chemistry of planets that
are orbiting other stars so if we
finally I think it's more likely to find
out on Mars a little swine sooner on
Mars than on an exoplanet that's cuz the
technology isn't complete because we're
there we're on Mars we're literally
digging things up eating them a robot is
eating them trying to figure out if it
was once alive yeah we're there and when
you're looking at exoplanets you got to
be really clever you have to wait for
the planet to pass in front of the host
star and look at the light from the host
star as it passes through the atmosphere
of the host planet and if the oxygen is
there it takes away certain signature of
light from the host planet from you just
survive this I can't believe scientists
have the patience to do any of this yeah
yeah so so it's a great question tell
your daughter thanks for getting you to
call in for yeah so tell her probably
Mars
she picked Mars excellent excellent
all right so thanks Geoff rakonin yeah
all right